and the grammy goes to savage
megan the stallion featuring beyonce
[Applause]
megan the stallion took home the 2021
grammy for best rap performance for the
remix of her song
savage featuring beyonce
[Applause]
oh my god oh y'all everybody in the room
all my people in the room
y'all thank you lord god is the first
person i want to thank
oh my gosh um my grandma thank you mimi
for not you know making me stop music to
finish school
um thank you mama
for pushing me and knowing that i was
gonna be here safe to say
megan was very excited about her honor
thank you beyonce like
i just i still can't even believe this
like what what
me last year the rapper talked to et
about the success
of the song it just really blows my mind
every day like when i write
music or when i'm like rapping i'm not
really thinking oh my gosh
it's gonna go crazy like i'm just making
it because i like it
and and i know my hotties are gonna like
it but just for it to have blown up the
way it did i was like
oh my gosh this is so crazy and then for
me to have
the beyonce remix i was like
what's happening at the time megan could
not believe she got beyonce on the remix
like i have been speaking it into
existence like i want to do something
beyonce i want a song with beyonce
but literally after sky blue it came
like beyonce is gonna do this and i was
[Music]
like